was macht corona mit polen
deswegen und damit herzlich willkommen
zur allerersten folge von trading mein
name ist bastian himmer
ich bin filmemacher und journalist und
für training durch rosberg
ich will wissen was hinterher steckte
von land trends steckt und wird nämlich
heute einem thema das seit beginn der
pandemie für furore gesorgt hat corona
und porn schon zu beginn der krise gehen
clubs wie real in den menschen mit
schutzkleidung sex haben diverse medien
berichten corona pornos geboren während
des lockouts verzeichnen porno streaming
seiten nutzer rekorde und direct sales
plattform auf den popstars
selbstgemachte clips direkt an fans
verkaufen können schießen auf einmal
durch die decke welche macht haben die
danke ohne blumen plattform was bedeutet
es für alle anderen und welche risiken
gehen damit vielleicht auch einher
kurzum was macht cola mit prof
ich recherchiere und geh rein in die
branche zu insidern und beteiligten
erster gedanke ich fliege in die usa
vielleicht der internationale hotspot
pornografie fällt aber mit krone
einreiseverbot geradeaus also erstmal
weiter zum zweiten ort auf meiner liste
barcelona gerade auch kein einfaches
reiseziel aber da komme ich hin
mildes klima aufgeschlossene menschen
günstige flüge geile stadt findet auch
die pornoindustrie barcelona ist zum
global capital of porn aufgestiegen sagt
jedenfalls eine industrie berichte
plattform ex ernster hier bin ich
richtig ich immer die man sprechen der
die industrie kennt der von porno lebt
und von corona boom selbst betroffen ist
hier im kapital der porno suche ich ein
polster denn trotz ausnahmezustand steht
das geschäft mit porno nicht im
gegenteil im netz bin ich auf jet
presley gestoßen und die produziert seit
der pandemie am fließband er ist ein
echter star der branche kennt sich mit
online plattformen aus
jd habe ich eingeladen zu einem break
kollegin canela und einem freund
regisseur sind auch mit an bord sie alle
lassen sich regelmäßig auf corona testen
wie übrigens auch ich nach dieser reise
aber viel angst vor dem virus scheint
hier niemand zu haben
[Musik]
also filme ab denn die beiden sind stars
im web und braucht nachschub für die
plattform
zuerst stehen instagram shops auf dem
programm alles gerade noch jugendfrei
damit heizen sie später die verkäufe der
clips wirklich verändert
über plattformen wie modelhart defense &
manage verkaufen die performerin
direkter nicht wenn die netzwerke
funktionieren ein bisschen wie instagram
nur eben mit kostenpflichtigen pro user
von und werden über neuste informiert
bezahlt wird im pay per view oder abo
modell ein teil geht an die plattform
der rest an die performer mehr traffic
jf
[Musik]
und das geht bei ihren fans am besten
babyöl fahrzeugen und anspruch für
jetten kanäle heißt die pandemie also
vor allem mehr arbeit und mehr umsatz
und ich bin ich nur das erste mal beim
porno sydney ich halte auch noch die
kamera drauf um das hier für euch zu
dokumentieren
wild wird euch trotzdem noch mehr zeigen
aber youtube möchte das nicht
das war bizarr
vielleicht ist was dran dass die
pandemie auch neue möglichkeiten schafft
klarheit und kanäle sind doch absolute
selbst vermarktungs profis die konstant
social media füttern und einfach wissen
wie es geht
aber was bedeutet die krise für
diejenigen die gerade nicht auf den
plattform ab sahen was ist die andere
seite der medaille
ich finde die man sprechen der nicht
direkt vom online group profitiert und
der den mut hat auch die dunklen seiten
industrie anzusprechen und den finde ich
in barcelona
dies war
der journalist ismael lopez faust ist
ein bekannter kritiker der industrie in
sachen porno hat er den durchblick war
früher als ghostwriter importance tätig
und selbst an vielen ports mit dabei
dann machte er aus seiner erfahrung ein
brisanten bericht das buch stellte er
als free download ins netz
seitdem informierte er über psychische
abhängigkeit gewalt und drogen im
business deshalb wurde er mehrfach
bedroht über das erlebte zu schweigen in
zeiten der krise von 1 x 3 mehr
regulierung für porn produktion und für
online streaming plattform die
epizentren der industrie
denn die gewinn grad noch mehr an
bedeutung das ist das flaggschiff der
branche eine tube zeit auf der user
selbst content hoch und runterladen
können der großteil des gratis quasi das
youtube der porn bonhof ist teil von
mega power player meint gibt zudem
zahlreiche seiten gehören und meint geht
bringt es auf mehrere milliarden klicks
pro jahr spielt damit krieg technisch in
einer liga mit seiten wie amazon und
wikipedia allein borna hat 115 millionen
besucher täglich
im letzten jahr haben sich über 98.000
neue models angemeldet und werden krone
liegt kommt noch einmal zu tief über 24
prozent mehr traffic als gewöhnlich
dieser boom sorgt auf der seite für
zahlreiche trends einer davon waren
hardcore porno clips oft mit
hunderttausenden dieses wie der von sql
zum jazz ist das vegas
die beiden leben in der porn hochburg
las vegas und ich habe sie per mail
kontaktiert ich will wissen wie sich ihr
leben mit corona und seitdem die
reinhild verändert hat schließlich hat
der krebs über nacht zu stars gemacht
und da ich nicht hinreisen kann haben
sie es für mich dokumentiert alles
selbst gefilmt darin hansen
[Musik]
sie profitieren also von der pandemie
und den großen plattformen wobei die
professionellen studios geschlossen
bleiben wovon auch die jetzt an wollen
dass die beiden für sie produzieren
dabei drehen sie weiterhin alles selbst
und zu hause all das klingt gar nicht so
verkehrt sind die schattenseiten also
doch vielleicht nur die ausnahme und
eigentlich profitieren die meisten
beteiligten von corona boom
und was sagen eigentlich die big player
die großen studios dazu
schließlich scheint die ja gerade an
bedeutung zu verlieren in barcelona will
keiner der großen mit mir sprechen
ausnahmezustand man drehe gerade nicht
ich nehme kontakt zum kind auf ein major
player im fetisch bereich und erreichte
ihren regisseur champion las vegas mehr
homemade productions durch corona was
heißt das für die großen
[Musik]
jappy willigt ein das für mich zu
dokumentieren er zeigt mir seine sets
und besprechen per skype über die
auswirkungen von conan happy macht einen
netten eindruck
soweit man das beurteilen kann von
seinem studio kann ich das nicht
wirklich sagen
ich bin total der bdsm und zwar hardcore
happy sagt alles nur fetish und hot aber
feel free was haltet ihr von dem kram
mein ziel war es zu verstehen was keiner
für die studios heißt antwort home
office quellen per webcam
maschinengehäuse die uhr gp sagt zu
würden wenigstens alle bezahlt und
weiterhin passiere alles in absolut
kontrollierten bedingungen für jackie
ist zustimmung extrem wichtig
aber auch das thema vergewaltigung und
horn kocht seit corona hoch die ngo
achse des kreis sorgt dabei für furore
einige kritiker bezeichnen die als
christlicher hardliner fest steht nicht
unbedingt freunde vom korn aber ihre
vorwürfe haben es in sich es gebe
unzählige videos von vergewaltigen und
anderen straftaten auf porno ab sie
wollen die seite zu fall bringen
die video dazu hat 25 millionen views
ihre petition über zwei millionen
unterzeichner
ich nehme kontakt zu leader michael
white von exit skrei auf dem kopf hinter
treff ging habe sie sieht eine gefahr in
den blumenhof productions auf den cubes
ein kameramann ist für uns vor ort in
den usa ja es gab solche unfälle in der
vergangenheit aber sind die tubes
wirklich voll damit lakers
anschuldigungen sind heftig und porn hat
weiß sie entschieden zurück man kämpfe
gegen alle formen von illegalen inhalten
im internet und haben
überdurchschnittliche schutzmechanismen
installiert kontrolliere jeden einzelnen
upload
all das kann ich nicht überprüfen
feststeht konnten auf youtube
hochzuladen ist einfach meist reicht ein
bestätigungs klick und eine
e-mail-adresse
all das will er ändern und dafür reist
länger sagt ja nach washington um hier
mit entscheidern zu sprechen aber
externe regulierung und porno das
durchzusetzen scheint kompliziert und
das beginnt schon beim zugang ein
beispiel in deutschland und vielen
anderen ländern ist die verbreitung von
pornografie an minderjährige verboten
aber wirklich durchgesetzt wird das fast
nirgends meist genügt ein klick um zu
den inhalten zu gelangen
alterskontrollen per ausweis wie england
es einführen wollte sind bis jetzt meist
krachend gescheitert aus
datenschutzgründen die wachsende macht
der tube summe homepage productions
scheint automatisch auch weniger
transparenz zu bedeuten
dabei scheint die in zeiten der globalen
pandemie wichtiger denn je
was kann man also tun um die beteiligten
besser zu schützen ohne dabei gleich
porn verbieten zu wollen
im herzen von barcelona gibt es jemanden
der genau das versucht und auch in
zeiten der pandemie mit alternativen
ansätzen eine immer größere netz
community bekommt die feministische
porno pionieren erika last
[Musik]
während der pandemie hat erika mit der
kampagne pay for japan für furore
gesorgt
sie wollen faire produktionsbedingungen
schaffen und kritisiert die fried
[Musik]
ich habe ich habe respekt und werte sagt
erika sind die bei ihren film sehr
wichtig und gerade laufen die
vorbereitungen für den aller ersten dreh
seit beginn der pannen
die vorbereitungen am set laufen auf
hochtouren alle wurden am vortag auf
corona getestet doch die angst vor dem
virus tritt mit
[Musik]
und auch an einem feministischen poncet
heißt es am ende des schauers chor und
trotz ethischen werten corona tests
handschuhen und masken die
grundsätzlichen risiken von pornografie
für die beteiligten bleiben werden durch
die panne sogar noch einmal verstärkt
bei wirklich alles perfekt läuft kann
ich natürlich nicht beurteilen aber ich
habe auf jeden fall das gefühl dass alle
im office aufrichtig daran arbeiten eine
transparente faire reform von
pornografie zu etablieren fest steht
aufgrund der pandemie hersteller branche
treu krämer stimmung und die kommt nicht
und dunkler auslösen
jetzt steht die zweite welle
wahrscheinlich vor der tür das ganze
könnte sich also noch intensivieren was
also tun
müssen die konsumenten ihren konsum mehr
hinterfragt und welche verantwortung
trifft die plattform brauchen wir am
ende einfach mehr kontrolle
wie seht ihr das wenn sie die in der
pflicht schreibt eure meinung in die
kommentare und lassen uns hier
diskutieren
weitere spannende geschichten rund um
den globus schaut dem auslandsjournal
vorbei das war es von mir ist
[Musik]